c'est quelque chose
elle était attendue une tempête qui
balaie tout l'est du pays à chaque fort
de ce fait toujours qu'ils se trompent
un puits soit ici la france qui sont pas
trompés je pense qu'on va en avoir plus
je pense qu'il n'en observe
à sherbrooke et en beauce il annonçait
45 cm de neige en gaspésie jusqu'à 60
et montréal et québec on attendait une
vingtaine de centimètres le mélange de
froid et devant est inhabituel
il surprend même les habitués comme ceux
des nageurs à 15h à de la neige puis
c'est l'habitude kakina gédoux fait 2 -
2 - 4 mai - saint-malo - étrangle seror
que ce soit à pied en voiture ou en
avion
les déplacements sont pénibles ça glisse
tu appelles tu et ça reste coincé
à montréal dans la mythique au but
devant les autobus n'osent pas s'y
aventurer
d'un bout à l'autre du pays des tronçons
d'autoroutes sont fermées et les sorties
de route se sont multipliés à la halle
au port de montréal des centaines de
vols ont été annulés
plus tôt aujourd'hui les voyageurs nager
en pleine incertitude sa duc s'est
reportée à une oeuvre
voilà on a regardé sur internet deux
fois tout est normal encore pour
l'instant vont se croiser les doigts
il est exposé dans la lutte est revenu
l'été à une heure qui nous dit la
tempête fait son bout de chemin vers
l'est
il a été le vote aussi à moncton
l'aéroport est vide tous les vols sont
suspendus jusqu'à tard ce soir
restez à la maison c'était le principal
conseil en ce jour de neige
prochain défi le retour au travail lundi